our next guest is the most talented
person her legendary work in film
television and music oh and there's
broadway too has earned her countless
awards and honors plus she sold more
than 20 million albums worldwide
no big deal
now she's a judge on the brand new
singing competition queen of the
universe please welcome the one and only
vanessa williams
[Applause]
hello
i was
looking at your accolades last night and
i just felt the need to list them four
emmy nominations you've got grammy
nominations a tony nomination three sag
award nominations seven naacp image
awards and three satellite awards okay
so when you have that many yeah do you
have a moment
in your life because that's so spread
out and so many was there another like
light bulb moment like all right i'm on
the right track i'm doing well i'm
making it
well i think
funny enough uh when i was miss america
i won at 20 years old i was a junior in
college from syracuse university and i
remember yeah yeah 1983
yeah that was a long time ago and i was
doing an appearance uh near northwestern
university i was in the hotel getting
ready and i was watching soul train
because back in the day that's what you
did on saturday morning you'd watch soul
train it's the best it's the best it was
an institution
exactly so when i saw my name on the
soul train scramble board they're like v
a and i was like what vanessa williams
that's when i knew that i had made it i
love that that's so fun gold train
scramble board i made it at 20 years old
you know what i did the super bowl
that's like one of those things where i
sang the anthem that was like out of
body experience because it's just bigger
than life saying at the academy awards
that's right again live the colors of
the wind from pocahontas and again those
are the the moments where you can say oh
yeah i did the academy awards ah i did
the world series oh you know so it's
been it's been gold train but soul train
started
out which i love that so much i was also
listening to your daughter lion babe
music she's everything thank you i'm so
proud of gosh her daughter
your four kids my four kids
and
i i i'm just mesmerized by her music and
her
appearance and her voice i mean what
yeah my kids are still kids kids but you
see the talent though and you see what
their skill set is she's talented and
she's grown into an amazing artist she
broke over in uh in london on polydor uk
and then you know her and lucas i have
this amazing group called lion babe so
yeah it's so hot it's so cool like she's
dynamic and all of your kids one thing i
really love reading was that you and
your mom used to make clothes and you
would get mccall's paddle of course and
yes and butterwork of course i love this
you remember the wrap skirt everyone had
to make a wrap skirt it was the easiest
thing anyone who had a pattern like we
had whole mech back in the day so we had
home eq you had to learn how to sew and
learn how to cook and bake which was
great yeah just a couple of recipes at
seventh grade that's all you need you
know still at that level
seriously and the old wrap skirt that
was our first pattern that we had to do
and master that and i had one one was
kind of denim but it was like an ombre
denim i have no idea where it is but oh
i want to watch that now because it's
probably so on trend exactly you had a
job when you were younger also that many
jobs i i started babysitting at
11 which i think everybody had to
babysit to get money
um i sold avon uh yeah along with
selling girl scout cookies which i did
as well oh i love girl scout cookies
that's my cookie that's your cookie okay
which i i think i know what yours are
what the men's are the best
well i knew most of my neighbors because
i grew up in my hometown so i could
knock on you know mrs goldstein's door
and say hi can you are you interested in
this lipstick we've got some new colors
or i'm selling thin mints or you know
samoas how many boxes can i give you and
you'd check off your little checklist
maybe a tag along exactly oh my god
exactly but that was you know those were
back in the day and you know funnily
enough i moved back to my hometown so
yeah i was right yeah i'm back in my
hometown my kids went to the same
schools i went to it's crazy i know okay
so you have so much experience
so being under your tutelage
in this new show um and i love rue so
much
and um
i mean i how do you approach guiding
people on the show are you honest do you
give them tough love are you gentle
well i have a new show on paramount
called queen of the universe and it is a
drag show but it's a global drag show
but they are singing for real no lip
syncing there singing for real so we are
the judges uh myself uh trixie mattel uh
uh michelle visage and leona lewis from
from london we are the judges uh graham
norton is the host i mean
really incredible people guiding yeah
these and we all have experience exactly
yeah so we can talk i mean i can talk
about broadway i can talk about stage
presence uh they're wearing in ears so i
was like can you hear yourself is the
music too loud you seem a little off so
we're we're giving encouragement i mean
we we're we're truthful you know if it
wasn't great and they didn't bring the
energy that they needed we'll call them
out on it but it all is to encourage
them to get better and they get better
and better every episode
[Music]
you